um these infections 29 173 new
infections
yesterday minister sustained drop uh
over
five days how optimistic are we as a
government that this is going in the
right direction
well i think you know we all know how
quickly it can go back up again and
whilst it's very good news to see those
numbers going down i think it does show
how important it is that we continue to
take issues like self-isolation really
seriously as well and continue to
encourage people to get that
vaccine and the double vaccine indeed
because that's going to be the way that
we get out of this longer term
i'm glad you brought up the
self-isolation because the bloke that
came up
with the app professor christopher
fraser chief scientific advisor for the
app says
really we should be scrapping that uh
self-isolation requirement now and
replacing it with
double jab um is the government going to
take note of that
well i think we do know what an
important tool it is for self-isolation
to get on top
of the on top of the virus but from
um august the 19th of course sorry
august the 16th
of course all adults that have been
double vaccinated they won't need to
self-isolate unless they've got symptoms
or a positive test so that's again
another reason to really encourage
people to go out and get that second
vaccine
yeah the unions are agreeing with you
actually certainly the rmt
union this morning saying that actually
um
it doesn't matter that they're some of
their members are double
vaccinated they should be allowed to
stay at home if they've been pinned
and that the government is putting their
members health at risk by asking them
and expecting them to go in
so i think it is important that we also
minimize the disruption
to the economy um and that's why
we've looked at certain really really
crucial sectors and are saying that in
those circumstances those double
vaccinated
adults if they um haven't had the
positive test they don't have any
symptoms then they can continue to work
but this is a really really small
number of people in order to keep those
truly essential services running in
services like for example police fire
border control um some of the food
sector
and and some elements of transport as
well um but as i said the key
date to move forward to is just in a
couple of weeks time that august the
16th
where all adults who've had that double
vaccination and they will be able to
um avoid the self-isolation unless
they've got symptoms or the positive
test
so are you saying to the rmt union who
are threatening legal action on behalf
of its members that it is safe
for their members to go to work uh
despite them being pinged if they've
been double jabbed
i'm saying we need to continue to keep
those critical areas of the economy open
as far as possible we need to move on to
this next stage which will be
at the moment is on august the 16th and
that's an important date
because uh that's a date by which we'll
have more adults double vaccinated but
also will have had that fire break since
the end of the school term as well so
that's why
we're looking forward to that date yeah
but to
answer my question minister is it safe
uh
for rmt members to go to work even if
they've been pinged if they've been
double vaccinated
every single employer obviously needs to
look at the safety of their staff as
they've done
throughout this and they've had good
guidance we've got many employers who
are saying
um in these really really crucial
sectors of the economy
uh and it will only be the most
the most critical of the critical
workers if i can say that
who for those workers um if they have
had the double vaccination
um then they can come back um if they
continue to have that negative test so
it's okay for them to risk their health
i think it's really important that all
employers look at the safety
arrangements that are put in place and
they continue to have discussions with
the health officials
and this is something that we're
continually looking at as we move
through the next stages of the pandemic
okay let me put it another way then if
it is safe for them if they've been
double jabbed to go to work even if
they've been pinged why not for others
so what we need to do is make sure that
we get as many vaccinations into
people's arms because that is an
absolutely key part of beating the
vaccination which is why
we want to have the next couple of weeks
of getting those more vaccinations
before we move into that next stage for
the
rest of the double vaccinated adults but
we've also got
many of those in these really really
essential services saying
um you know if they can if they have
adults who have had the double
vaccination who've had the protection
that
a couple of weeks after you get your
vaccination as well
that they would uh be able to return to
the workplace but the employers will
obviously need to look at that very
closely as well
and many employers have been putting in
places um mechanisms to make sure that
that can also keep workers safe
yeah so if you are double jabbed and
you've had a fortnight after your last
job
then you are safe to go to work well we
know that people can still get
kovid after having had a double jab but
we also know that having had the double
jab means it's far less likely to be a
really serious or life-threatening
illness and and so that's why it's not
quite so simple as saying
you know once you've had your double
vaccination you'll never get covered
because that's simply not the case
but we know that having the double
vaccination reduces both the chances of
serious
life-threatening illnesses but also
reduces the amount of transmission that
you'll give to other people
yeah what's the magical day of mystical
magical day of the 16th of august then i
mean i had my second job
in april um you know it's a long time
since i had my second job
why will i be safe on the 16th of august
but potentially not safe
today this is all about keeping the
whole community and how we react
together as a community and as i said
that the date the 16th of august was set
because it's
been a fire break since the end of the
school term
so we won't have um seen so many people
mixing in schools
but also it'll have meant that more
people will have been able to get that
second vaccination and as i said the
second vaccination can
help reduce the amount of transmission
that's going through community
yeah um talk to me about travel
if you would please spain france greece
what's the government's
advice if people have a holiday book for
those countries
well as as we know we've always looked
at each different country's situation
individually and i would advise people
to look at the advice that's coming
through from golf dot uk
and make sure that they follow that
guidance on each of these different
countries i obviously can't preempt any
decisions that might be made by the
transport team
as children's minister i i won't preempt
their decisions
no indeed not but you are representing
the government this morning so
the third of a million brits that headed
out over the weekend
they will be anxiously wondering whether
they're going to have to shut
cut short their holidays um to come back
to the uk if we change the rules again
what
what is the discussion within government
well i think it's really important that
people
do look at the rules and people who have
booked holidays overseas will have known
that
you know there's a risk of situations
changing but we've
now had the pandemic you know for many
many months now and as we've all seen
the situation can change and that's why
it's very important that
um we in the uk also look at what's
happening with other countries overseas
and that people do follow
the guidance that's appropriate to the
country that they're returning from
yeah are you uh holidaying overseas this
year no
okay uh talk to me about uh we talked
about the 16th of august let me take you
further forward to
october uh students returning to
university
do they have to be fully vaccinated in
order to attend lectures
so what we've always done throughout
this pandemic is prioritized access
to university um and one of the things
that we really want to do is encourage
young people to get that double
vaccination because as i've said that's
the way that you'll minimize
disruption um to your own university
career and i will certainly be
encouraging both of my students sons to
have their second vaccination before
they go back to university
will it become a requirement
no i we must make sure that we continue
to prioritize education and if they want
to
be able to avoid the self-isolation
such as we have said for other adults
double vaccinated adducts by august 16th
if you have not got a positive test if
you don't have symptoms you won't need
to self-isolate so if the students who
are returning to university that's a
really important
okay i think that's both of your young
boys are trying to get in touch with you
via your computer as we're chatting this
morning
and let's talk about kids that are
younger you're here to talk about
adoption today
yes this is a really really important
message that i'm giving today we're
launching a new adoption strategy today
and
the really good news is that over the
past decade the number of children
are waiting for adoption has more than
halved
and we know that the best place for
children is to be in a loving stable
family but unfortunately there are some
children who
can't stay with their own birth parents
and for some of those children being
adopted is the best solution so in our
adoption strategy that we're launching
today
we're significantly increasing support
for adoptive families we set up the
adoption
support fund um about six years ago
and that provides ongoing therapy and
family support to adoptive families and
we're
more than doubling that today but also
putting in
new national standards to make sure that
all
adoption across the country is well
supported
and that will be through the regional
adoption agencies that we've been
setting up over the past few years and
which cover
nearly all of the country and we really
want to make sure that that children who
do
need that loving stable forever family
can get there as quickly as possible so
we're also encouraging
our doctors from all sorts of
backgrounds or different ethnicities
or walks of life to step forward um to
consider adopting and
making that loving family for a child oh
do you need to have a cough it looks as
though you needed a little bit of water
then i didn't know if it was that or you
were being very emotional you need a bit
of water don't you
i just wanted to ask you quickly have
you bought your cup of tea lovely um
before i let you go lots of friends
asking me over the weekend when you get
that government minister
on the program on monday morning ask
them whether we've reached the peak of
the third wave and we can start to go
down the other side
and at least have some respite over the
summer what should i tell them
okay i wish it was always so that easy
to predict what's going to happen
next it's obviously been very good and
heartening to see that
numbers testing numbers come down the
past couple of days but we know it can
go up again
so i would just encourage uh people to
go out and get that vaccination get us
that second vaccination because that is
why we're seeing so many fewer people
getting really sick from
this um virus but i'd also encourage
people to you know
still do follow those rules and if you
are asked to self-isolate
then do do that because that's the way
that you continue to protect others
and i thought for your health secretary
uh this morning um he got a proper
kicking over the weekend after saying
that we shouldn't cower from covid
um he misspoke is was it any more than
that
well he apologized for that and and
quite rightly deleted his tweet and has
given a very
uh heartful uh apology i mean sajid
himself has lost relatives to kovid
and and knows that awful grief that so
many families have
um but i think what he's trying to do is
encourage us that we can also
have that hope from the vaccine that
people
by having that vaccine and you know
they've are
many many people in this country have
stepped forward and leading the world
and it's
you know seven out of ten adults have
now had their double vaccine
but we do need to continue to keep that
momentum up and especially for younger
adults to please step forward because
that will protect you from getting sick
and it will protect the people that you
love and your neighbors as well
okay good to talk to you i must let you
go